we were talking about traveling you know
because of what happened with that no
true Dom fire yeah I was wondering if
you were as affected as everyone else I
had friends texting and tweeting do you
see what's happening in Paris but didn't
carry which tell he reminded me years
ago some sponsors sent Gary and Sal on a
trip to Europe somebody would would have
told you that you'd end up in Europe
going on a family vacation with Sal and
his wife the guy who used to call you a
horse toothed jackass every day he's the
torture you yeah and then it was a good
weird and then all of a sudden he's
hanging out with you Sal and I bonded on
that trip I end up loving him tell your
story well the first part is we went to
Notre Dame hey Sal and and when we got
there Sal was surprised that it was a
church because he thought we were going
to a college you know you have Saint
Pat's here right you're in Paris let's
see it it's a monument that is the
epitome of Gothic architecture look who
you're talking to who cares
you didn't marvel at the flying
buttresses what the hell is that thing
how are like arkad I know well is some
stuff like that what was that the Ark
everyone oh well what is that what is it
right Robin what is it it's just this
big Ark in the middle of Paris and no
true the octave tree off whatever is it
was just a [ __ ] little arch it was a
broom again if you get out and look at
it as incredible and it is the Tomb of
the Unknown Soldier well that's a nice
man told me Mary was charmed by Sal on
the trip for some reason she really was
she had big reservations about going on
the trip she's like I don't know and I'm
like listen it's a war it's a free trip
to Europe you don't want to hang out
with them you don't have to and he
charmed her Wow
she loves him she loves al yeah we have
fun we just had a good time